the Porsche Museum in Stuttgart houses
all the notable models and vehicles even
farm machinery and the famous German
sports car makers history but for this
event that classic and vintage models
are just a backdrop all eyes are on a
world premiere
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
the new Porsche Cayenne
Portia's Oliver Booma of Porsche
explains that in 2002 Porsche entered a
new segment SUVs and he says Porsche
succeeded in rolling out the sports car
for the segment since then over 760
thousand have been sold and he's
convinced the new Cayenne will pick up
on that success and it has all the
qualities it needs to do so the large
wheels and flat windscreen speak a very
clear design language as does the
c-pillar slanted forward and the big
roof spoiler conscious Tomatis curette
is excited about it
he feels comfortable right off in a seat
that's adjustable in every direction
north south east and west and you can
make it longer and narrower or wider on
the right side are the handles typical
of the Cayenne so if the ever strikes
out cross country as improbable as that
may be his passenger can hold on tight
the driver can't of course because he'll
need both hands on the steering wheel
there's a 12 inch display for the
infotainment system in the center
console similar to the one in the
Panamera and also as in the Panamera the
actual buttons are being replaced by
touch elements on the glass screen in a
glass flesh that makes a smart
impression as do the two displays to the
right and left of a property comet are
an essential part of any Porsche needs I
mess up
three choices of LED headlights are
available for the Cayenne including
standard LED headlamps and the 84 diode
matrix beam technology he's a pawn
Montes notices this Porsche stance on 21
inch wheels
31 and 1/2 centimeters wide and back and
a bit narrower in front it's the first
time the Cayenne is front and back
wheels have been different and it's the
first time it's had rear axle steering
that reduces the turning circle
considerably and the chances of smacking
one of these expensive rims against a
curb for an embossed item and mocked the
designers face the task of making the
SUV immediately recognizable as a
Porsche but also as robust as an
off-road vehicle ought to be and the
grandson of the car makers founder
thinks they accomplish their task
amazingly well welcome Porsche recalls
that the first sketches looked almost
like a clumpy vehicle but he describes
the final version as a real whopper more
attractive and just plain beautiful of
you other drivers on the road often half
of the Cayenne is from the rear
shrewdness the tight Montes likes the
red tail light strip across the back
already familiar from other Porsche
models it's combined with the badging
under glass he thinks that looks very
upscale and high-quality and it fits in
with the taillights three-dimensional
graphic look the cargo space is neat
with the sub-woofer below the floor if
the buyer has opted for the exclusive
boozes sound system the cargo space can
be expanded by just shifting the rear
seat forward a bit there isn't a lot of
room above because the c-pillar that
gives the car a much sportier look
outside reduces the space inside
it was vinegar plugs - v6 turbocharged
gasoline engines are available Vitamix
montes points out that ever since the
Cayenne was rolled out in 2002 every
facelift or redesign has made it
sporty-er except the III as it was
designated internally the new Cayenne
looks more like a classic Porsche than
any Cayenne before and he thinks if he
reviews it for the show he may well
discover that it drives more like a
classic Porsche than any other Cayenne
as well